is America still the greatest country on
earth is it even something to be proud
of anymore let's figure it out so to set
this up this videos gone viral millions
and millions of plays it's a rant from
Jeff Daniels character will McAvoy in
the newsroom on why America is no longer
the greatest country in the world every
leftist and their dog has likely sent it
to you it's pretty entertaining it's
worth a watch but is it true is any of
it true let's watch are you willing to
say here tonight whether you lean right
or left I voted for candidates run by
both major parties hey before we get to
anything else that's a red flag right
there this is the kind of non partisan
journalism that only occurs in Hollywood
it's a sleight-of-hand trick meant to
set him up as objective in order to pave
the way for what becomes a leftist
anti-american political agenda driven
diatribe what makes America the greatest
country in the world well Louis and
Sharon said it diversity and opportunity
and freedom and freedom
I'm not letting you go back to the
airport without answering the question
well our Constitution is a masterpiece
James Madison was a genius
the Declaration of Independence is for
me the single greatest piece of American
writing yet later on in the interview
he's going to allude to his support the
consistent progressive abuse of the
Constitution because you know he's
objective you know why people don't like
liberals because they lose if smart how
come they lose it always and with a
straight face okay we're going to get in
the substance really quickly but again
this is a trick in an attempt to feign
even-handedness see his one criticism of
the liberal is that of strategy not
principal contrast this with what comes
next and with a straight face you're
gonna tell students that America is so
star-spangled awesome that we're the
only ones in the world who have freedom
Canada has freedom there it is the key
the equivalency between the United
States and the freedom of all other
countries they say that they're free so
it must be so but is that freedom the
same is it even close well let's take
Canada for starters he mentions Canada
that's the place where I was raised
a place where pastors have been banned
from not even for practicing free speech
from the pulpit a place where the right
to spontaneously protest and peaceably
assemble has actually been banned by the
province of Quebec a place where there's
a gun registry because you're not even
allowed to own a handgun unless you
prove to the government your right to
self-preservation and they'll likely
turn you down anyway a place where
freedom of the press is virtually
non-existent because there's a monopoly
on TV news from government-funded media
a place where freedom of speech really
isn't a right at all
Canada has freedom Japan has freedom the
UK France Italy Germany Spain Australia
Belgium has freedom so 207 sovereign
states in the world like 180 of them
have freedom all right and got you
obviously I can't go through all of
these countries I'd encourage you to do
your own research what I can tell you
beyond any shadow of a doubt is that not
only are none of these countries
anywhere near as free as the United
States but from the ground up none of
them were even intended to be places
like the UK was for the highest taxes in
the world actually surpassed only by the
other nations that Daniels so praises in
France Netherlands Italy Ireland and
Spain the UK where businesses can be
sued at
existence and shutdown simply for
holding unpopular religious beliefs and
of course access to firearms for the
purpose of self-defense is all but
non-existent because England saw how
that one ended up regulated militia and
all how about places he's mentioned like
Belgium and France where the UN has even
reported violations of religious freedom
of course with the exception of radical
Islam which is growing so strongly in
these parts of the world that they've
managed to establish their own anti
freedom communities courts and even laws
women's rights civil rights Human Rights
all of which are grossly and
consistently violated in the name of
Islam to which these bastions of
freedoms so incessantly cave and to
which they will ultimately be overrun
Japan a police found on the idea of
societal structures that were
predetermined and that you were either
born into nobility or a peasant a place
that sought to spread tyranny across the
globe several times over a place that
has made personal firearms for defense
all but illegal and religious freedoms
all but non-existent yeah I think we're
a little more free than Japan he got you
a sorority girl just in case you
accidentally wander into a voting booth
one day there's some things you should
know and one of them is there is
absolutely no evidence to support the
statement that were the greatest country
in the world
we're 7th and literacy 27th and math
22nd in science 49th and life expectancy
178th in infant mortality third and
median household income number four in
labor force and number four in exports
firstly the high infant mortality rate
in the united states is a debunked myth
and the fact that McEvoy the character
here uses it shows us again that
unbiased sleight of hand at play the
u.s. ranks relatively high on the infant
mortality rate largely because of the
country that numbers those neonatal
deaths notably in premature infant
fatalities unlike the other countries
that he so glorifies who basically leave
preemies to die and never counted as a
life you'd think a non-partisan
journalists here portrayed is will
McAvoy would be able to do a modicum of
research if he wanted the truth I get a
few things right it's true we don't have
the best life expectancy and that's a
consequence of personal freedoms nobody
will argue that personal responsibility
and free choice comes without the
negative ramifications of people who
seek to abuse it unlike so many other
countries with low expectancy rates that
come from famine and from lack the
problem the United States faces
that of such overabundance and such
freedom of choice that you can over
indulge yourself into an early death in
a free country you're free to do so it's
also why the United States dominates in
nearly all physical endeavors in the
record books because that same freedom
of choice that allows you to become a
gluttonous Pig
also gives you the ability to choose the
healthiest most optimal lifestyle
humanly possible it's why people
representing other nations in the
Olympics often come to train here
whether it's food technology or
cutting-edge training protocols that
same freedom that allows mediakron also
fosters an environment for the best of
the best ever sure we may not be the
number one country in the world when it
comes to math and sciences as it is hard
to compete with places like China where
your life path is determined at a young
age by the government based on your
genetics and your personal proclivities
again with freedom comes a greater
variance than in non free societies but
even there his numbers are misleading
the United States has historically and
continues to lead the world in both
manufacturing and innovation now before
you get your hate comments ready okay
it's true that on the global technology
index the United States ranks third here
behind Finland and Japan overall where a
more significant portion of innovation
may come from the government or
government contracts but the United
States still leads by a significant
margin on individual patents per capita
because despite the behemoth that we all
know about in Microsoft Apple and
Facebook it is still the one Enclave for
the small business owner entrepreneur
and innovator if you want to innovate if
you want to try your hand at success you
come to America still today our
continued innovation in the scientific
technological and medical fields yeah
it's a huge reason as to why the United
States is arguably still the biggest
factor in determining global economic
impact today but it's not our biggest
reason that would be that of our most
influential export that of culture film
stories TV music art there's never been
a culture quite like America's that has
saturated the world so effectively and
even if you personally don't like
American culture one needs only to look
at the top grossing films albums and
artists of all time to see the impact
it's had America dominates the list and
even with the exceptions from Canada or
the UK in order to find massive success
they first had to
move to and make it in the United States
why all these other countries that
McEvoy's so fervently praises and his
monologue find their top charts
dominated by American artists yet we
don't find ours filled to the brim with
theirs see whether you McEvoy their
self-loathing Americans in the YouTube
comments section here don't want to
accept that the world has already spoken
on culture with their dollar and it's
one of the greatest ironies that the
United States who is so often accused of
having no culture by leftist
multiculturalism proponents like McEvoy
is only able to make it our greatest
export because the rest of the world so
desperately wants to find themselves
included in it anyway I wanted to brag
on my country for a little bit but even
with that information none of those
things have anything to do with the
original point in freedom sure freedom
has ultimately produced unbelievable
results in the United States but even if
it didn't that doesn't change the
inherent moral superiority of the
concept of freedom given to a citizenry
over that of tyranny a toothless redneck
in a trailer park managing a 7-eleven
drinking bottom shelf beer who goes off
to fire rounds in the woods on Saturday
is still more free than an Olympic
medalist in gymnastics from China who
was told that she was going to be an
Olympic gymnast at six because she had
the right genetics and that her career
was going to be done by 12 freedom isn't
afforded to a citizenry inherently
because it produces better results its
afforded to them because it's right we
lead the world in only three categories
number of incarcerated citizens per
capita number of adults who believe
angels are real and defense spending
where we spend more than the next 26
countries combined 25 of whom her allies
now you can find some common ground here
the United States is not the best at
everything I'm certainly not here to
argue that our prison system is flawed
it could use some improvement I do find
it funny that he ultimately throws away
people who believe in angels is silly
because it completely undermines his
final point which I'll address in
closing but as mocking of America's
defense spending is iconic of one of the
greatest ironies lost on leftists in
that these other countries who enjoy
these selectively paltry freedoms
afforded to them by their governments
are still only able to do so because as
an opportunity afforded to them by the
United States of America that's right
I'm saying it Belgium
France Germany the UK Canada can all
enjoy their kind of freedom because of
the greatest peacekeeping organization
the world has ever known the United
States military yeah UK you want to
continue to enjoy your freedom of
censoring social media in the press
that's great you now have to defend the
free world
go Canada enjoys their freedom to censor
public speech that's fantastic let's
change one little variable here Canada
you now have to defend your borders your
vast underpopulated land rich in natural
resources that everybody else would want
to conquer and the United States is no
longer your big brother have at it
France wants to continue enjoying a
socialist 75 percent tax rate go nuts
now try keeping your country's economy
afloat while thwarting terror cells all
across the world while providing more
foreign aid to third-world countries in
the history of ever go a huge irony is
that many of these countries that Jeff
Daniels so openly praises actually found
themselves on the wrong side of freedom
actively fighting to end it only to be
thwarted by ignorant patriotic Americans
who ensured that it would live on for
generations to come
England France Germany Japan they're
going to be the ones to educate us on
freedom really we stood up for what was
right we fought for moral reasons we
passed laws struck down laws for moral
reasons we here's where he gets
emotionally disingenuous that we once
wrote laws for moral reasons well
there's a shred of truth to that why do
you think that is able to be all these
things and do all these things because
we were informed by great men men who
were revered
yeah the founding fathers were
intelligent but they weren't revered for
being informed they were revered for
their bravery for their principles for
their unwavering whether you like it or
not deeply held respect for a faith that
they saw as necessary for a government
to create a truly free people he's right
we did stand up for what was right see
for the first time from the ground up a
government was designed to give its
citizens true freedom not afforded to
them by these men but by a creator on
which no man would be allowed to
infringe the concept of inalienable
god-given rights that's what's
singularly unique about America and its
founders who were silly enough to
believe in angels if you like this video
subscribe by clicking my face or watch
one of these other videos next to me
it's free and maybe you'll enjoy them if
you don't it's still free